the idea of cultural appropriation is
absolute nonsense so that's that there's
no there's no difference between
cultural appropriation and learning from
one another they're the same thing now
that doesn't mean I can't that doesn't
mean that there's no step between people
there is you know and it doesn't mean
that just because you encounter someone
else's ideas you have an immediate right
to those ideas as if they were your own
but the idea that manifesting in your
own behavior some elements of another
culture the idea that that somehow
amoral is insane it's actually one of
the bases of peace you know one of the
things that the various groups of human
beings that exist have to offer each
other is the tremendous value of their
culture you know it's been really
interesting to me for example to watch
the responsive of all of everyone but
for this argument tea for young
Caucasian males to hip-hop you know
there's an aggressiveness about hip-hop
that's pretty attractive to young
Caucasian males and there's something
absurd about about that the spectacle of
the young Caucasian males taking on the
persona of inner-city black gang members
you know but but I'm sympathetic to it
because there's an aggressiveness to
that to that art form that the necessary
corrective to the insistence that the
highest moral virtue for a modern man is
harmlessness which is absurd women don't
even like harmless men they hate them
they like that
blow them apart you know what women want
are dangerous men who are civilized and
they want to help civilize them
that's Beauty and the beef so you know
I'll tell you a funny story because only
engineers could have come up with this
because they're the only ones that have
the unparalleled blindness to social
convention that would allow them to
discover it so the Google engineers I
like engineers by the way because
they're very straightforward the Google
engineers wrote a book a while back
called a billion wicked thoughts which
is a study of internet searches billions
of them literally and they were looking
a lot of pornography use and well
there's lots known about male
pornography use partly and it's easy to
understand
I mean males are you know pretty
visually oriented and what attracts them
to pornography is fairly straightforward
um you can tell that if you look at
graffiti in a men's washroom you know
it's like two circles in the Triangle
and the men are absolutely transfixed by
so for women the story is more complex
they use pornography to but it tends to
be literary because women tend to like
words more than they like visual stimuli
so the Google guys tried to track down
the archetypal structure of they didn't
use those words of female pornography
use and so some of you know how many of
you know what a Harlequin romance is
okay good so those are our typical
stories right that's the taming of the
wild man essentially by the by the
desirable and virginal woman and do you
think women don't want that then you
better bloody well come up with an
explanation for Fifty Shades of Grey
right which is the most the most rapid
selling novel in human history and
emerged at exactly the same time that
all of this noise about the lack of the
absence of gender roles is being
produced you know on mas it's like
perfect female fantasy it's exactly
architect Li correct it's Beauty and the
Beast so what the Google guys showed was
the structure of beauty of the beast
although they didn't use that as a
reference that the female pornographic
fantasy was wild guy you know somewhat
careless about the wants and desires of
others attractive to everyone therefore
high-status tamed by the magic of a
single woman
brought into a relationship with her
okay so but here's the comical part this
just made me laugh man it was like what
were the five categories of most
desirable male entity used most broadly
and female pornography
it's so embarrassing women you have to
cover your head while I say this vampire
world billionaire surgeon and pirate
Oh